In this final exam problem, we are given a
regular language in the form of a non-deterministic finite state
machine, and we want to construct another non-deterministic finite state
machine that accepts exactly the same strings, but backwards. So,
let's say we have this regular expression that accepts
strings that begin with an a and end with a
c and in between, have one or more occurrences of
bx and by. An example string that that regular expression
matches looks like this. a, bx, bx,
by, and c. So we do a, bx, by, and then c. So
here I have a finite state machine representation of that regular expression. We
start with an a, we require at least one bx or by. And then we can repeat
the bx and by afterwards as many times as we want, and we finish with a c.
Remembe,r the finite state machine we want to generate
will have to accept strings like this, where we begin
with a c, we then have yb, xb, xb,
and then a. Our strategy for doing that is going
to be basically reversing all of the edges. In
this finite state machine, to go the other direction, and
finishing it off by changing the start state with
the accepting state. Okay, so the first thing I'm going to
do is change the start state and the accepting state.
So now we start at 6, and finish at 1,
and now I'm going to change all of the arrows. And
we're done. If you look closely, you'll see that this
finite state machine. Matches exactly the same set as the
original one, finite state machine, but backwards. So, let's apply
that same methodology to coding our solution. So, I've started
coding the solution, and the first thing I do is
create a dictionary to contain the reversed edges, and I switch
the start and accepting states. Now I'm going to go through each
of the original edges, and right here on these three lines,
I'm just extracting the data from the original edge and the
original finite state machine to make it easier to manipulate later.
So, for this edge in the original finance state machine I'm
looking at, I'm going to go through each of its destinations, so
that I'm going to create an edge that goes the other direction.
And because the way we structure a data structure. I'm going
to have to do it in kind of a continuing fashion. I
can't just finish the edge. I have to look at every edge
in the original one before I can be certain that I've finished
the edge in the new finite state machine. So this line of
code sees if we've already created the beginning of this edge, and
that's going to overwrite the empty list we had before. And either
way, we're gong to set the new state of this edge in
the new finite state machine to be the concatenation
of the before list with the added state we got
from this iteration. And once we're done going through
the original finite state machine, we just return the result.